[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mu à plateau caillou pour cette première
édition du cross de la savane 700
courageux on découvrir un espace mais
surtout un territoire
magnifique vous allez voir ça va être
top
c'est parti
aussi bien ceux qui gèrent des arrivées
les départs on est 70 personnes job je
crois que
à combien suture et peu quand même
regardez ces bénévoles et sinon il
aurait pas de cause
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
b
[Musique]
tout
attendons
ont-ils envoyé la sauce
conte à la johnny dans sa van moer voilà
donc tous les flammes
c'est beau c'est beau la savane achats
d'or mais tu as le temps de regarder ou
pas bah oui ben regarde là là on est en
stationnement on regarde on admire géant
collectés en profite
bakou aze offre des croisettes il fait
là à les relances ça y est on est entré
dans l'intervalle saint paul un espace
naturel extraordinaire sur le point de
vue paysager l'historique botanique
on va voir tout ça avec le conservatoire
du littoral
c'est la clé de la course a commencé ici
dans quelques années et bien il n'y aura
plus à vannes mais à la place une zone
urbanisée
c'est à peu près un cinquième de la
surface qui va disparaître avant tout ça
la savane et cap là aussi c'est un
endroit qui était foncièrement utile et
nécessaire voire nécessaire aux
personnes qui habitent et à sa
périphérie faut s'imaginer une époque où
il y avait des centaines de boeufs moka
qui pâturent est dans la savane
alors on cultivait pas dans la savane si
vous faites attention vous allez voir en
vous promenant des vestiges de chemins
pavés
vous allez voir aussi des vestiges de
canaux d'irrigation pavés qui témoigne
justement qu'on a essayé aussi à cette
époque là en plus du pâturage de
valoriser la savane en y pratiquant donc
des cultures végétales aujourd'hui à peu
près 40 mille personnes qui habitent
autour de la savane du cap la houssaye
c'est un endroit majeur de ce point de
vue là parce que la savane est un des
rares espaces qui leur est offert en
proximité immédiate ils n'ont pas besoin
de prendre la voiture ils n'ont pas
besoin de descendre sur littoral ils
n'ont pas besoin de monter dans les eaux
retour dans le trail de la savane
j'essaye nicolas qui viennent métropole
et on continue on attaque la suite sais
tu vas pas tomber devant la caméra et
voilà c'est bon pour l'instant
l'humidité porte un peu préjudice
sourire à la fin ok mais la végétation
déjà ça rien à voir nous c est que
d'appeler les pinces et sec hockey dont
on a la chance quoi c'est ça tu veux
dire ouais c'est ça ouais bon courage
courage
j'ai hâte au maximum la halle courage à
ses murs eux ça va mais nous sommes
beaucoup vus de sarlat grand matin
dimanche
mais c est bien beau tout ça fait du
bien d'aider les autres ah c'est beau la
ligue 1 on peut applaudir parce que
c'est beau franchement bravo le dom
vous êtes au top alors ça va être dur
parce que là c'est de tourner parce que
tes collègues au département ça que tu
cours là bas c'est en catimini c'est
vrai mais oui mais là c'est bon je veux
pas ta personne 7 apporte quoi cette
discipline a du plaisir grand voyage et
au quotidien as au quotidien comme
benghazi à bureaux la whey pétille un
message via rail relance
[Musique]
oh
pis à l'upac a pris 7
ça fait du bien ça fait du bien acquis à
eux ou à toi petit pétillant pour les
camarades et ça fait plaisir tu vois
photo p voilà on en trouvait le lion de
la savane tu sais que tu russie lance la
machine
la fatigue se fait sentir plus que
quelques kilomètres avant de sortir la
savane l'occasion de faire le point sur
l'avenir de cette zone cas ce qu'elle va
devenir
donc c'est tout ce qu'on va voir l
avenir de cette savane c'est de rester
en l'état de savane en fait le
conservateur du littoral a commencé en
racheter une partie et puis avec
l'accord de la mairie de saint paul
il s'apprête à racheter une deuxième
partie de manière à préserver de toute
urbanisation environ 400 hectares
l'avenir donc ce sera une savane avec du
pâturage de bovins et de caprins et
articulé avec le brûlage dirigé et les
coureurs ont dû le voir quand on passe
près des lits lagon tout une parcelle
qui a été brûlé c'est donc en 2017
on va essayer en tout cas de limiter la
fermeture du milieu donc le brûlage le
pâturage et ce qui permettra après à
tous ces coureurs justement de revenir
dans la savane comme il comme ils le
font et d'avoir une servane beaucoup
plus ouverte
hier soir le brouillard août soit le
bruit des oiseaux c'est bien près d'une
heure et demie de course ya longtemps
que les premiers sont arrivés
salut l'hélicoptère
on va le voir un petit peu comment ils
ont vécu la course j'imagine qu'ils ont
eu moins de chaleur sans entendre un
petit coup de main pendant les
entraînements 1
regardez là enfin là mais tout ça est
super même comme ça il veut dire quoi
nous fait cette spl ce sport la pousse à
paris avec beaucoup rire moi
personnellement pour courir et en même
temps aussi moins personnellement me
aime bien la montagne surtout le grand
matin aux abords et dans la nuit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
question déterminante
comment fini les 100 derniers mètres et
plus coeur avec le choeur aller avec des
coeurs
[Musique]
oui mes shows de la case à bientôt